Narrator: This farmer's truck is covered
in rocks, hay, and sand.
Here's how Reece from Satisfying Clean
details filthy vehicles to look brand new.
The first step is to clear
any garbage in the interior.
Reece removes hay by hand
because it's faster than using a vacuum.
Next, he removes the floor
mats so he can access
all of the sand and dirt underneath.
Reece starts from the
top of the vehicle first
so that all of the sand
falls to the floor.
This is the best way to
avoid double-cleaning.
A special wet-and-dry detailing vacuum
is used to remove dirt, sand, and debris.
Vacuuming the floors takes the longest
but has the biggest payoff.
It's important to vacuum
those hard-to-reach areas
to try to get as much dirt and sand
out of the interior as possible
before moving on to the next step.
After dry-vacuuming,
Reece sprays an all-purpose
cleaner on the pedals
and uses a fingernail brush
to scrub off the dirt.
Next, the floor and carpets are sprayed.
Reece uses a drill brush
to agitate the floor.
This releases the dirt
so that it can be easily vacuumed up.
It's important to always
spray the interior first
so that the drill brush
doesn't damage any surfaces.
To finish cleaning the floors,
the remainder of the dirt is vacuumed up.
This process is repeated
throughout the vehicle
on different surfaces.
For smaller areas,
a detailing brush is used to remove dirt.
To finish the process,
Reece sprays a polish
on all the interior
plastics and wipes it away
to reveal a bright, shiny finish.
The process can take anywhere
from two to four hours,
but farmers are always pleased
with the transformation.